[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this episode we'll be covering the most
powerful spells in Harry Potter universe
at least in our opinion now determining
the power of spells can be quite
difficult and that's because each spell
has its own unique purpose and strengths
a good example of this would be Avada
Kedavra versus obliviate
now obliviate is used to erase memories
whereas Avada Kedavra is used for one
purpose to kill while they are both very
powerful spells respectively it's hard
to compare them because while they
aren't powerful in their own right they
are used for very different purposes
this list will be comprised solely of
the top 7 spells that one might use
against an opposing witch or wizard in
the event of a standoff some examples of
the functions of spells that one might
use in this sort of environment include
disarming your opponent defending
against opposing magic inflicting pain
or suffering causing paralysis and even
killing this list will not include
spells that are powerful but used to
achieve other sorts of results coming in
at number 7 on the list is stupefy
stupefy should be a staple spell in any
witch or wizard's arsenal it is also
known as the stupefying charm and is
used for stunning your opponent
rendering them unconscious it is an
excellent dueling spell as it does not
cause lasting effects or damage though
it could be appropriate to use in battle
if you do not wish to inflict lasting
harm on whoever you are battling known
defenses against stupefy include
renovate stupefy is used by almost all
of the main characters at one point or
another in the film's one famous
instance of this spell being used is
when Gellert Grindelwald used it on Mike
you cragger ovitch in order to steal the
Elder Wand make sure you've got stupefy
handy for when you need it but remember
that it won't work on trolls giants
dragons or half Giants hagrid included
coming in at number 6 on the list is
Sectumsempra Sectumsempra is the
incantation of a curse invented by
Severus Snape that causes lacerations
merging and cuts upon its target Snape
features this spell in his textbook for
advanced potion making the name
Sectumsempra comes from the combination
of two Latin words sect Asst which means
having been cut and semper which means
always using Sectumsempra is similar to
having an invisible sword on your
opponent and is nothing to be scoffed at
in battle the only known defence
treatment for Sectumsempra is vulnera
sanentur which eases the blood flow
heals the wound and removed the effects
of the curse one famous instance of this
spell being used is when Harry used it
on Malfoy unaware of its effects
shortly after Snape shows up and heals
Malfoy using vulnera sanentur coming in
at 5 on the list is expel yamas
expelling Armas is also known as the
disarming charm and is used to disarm
your opponent stripping them of their
wand it is commonly used in duels for
this purpose but in some instances where
the expeller Armas is particularly
powerful it can actually knock an
opponent down or send them flying
through the air
the name expelliarmus comes from the
Latin word expel air which means to
drive away and ARMA which means weaponry
expelliarmus was taught to students in
the dueling club while in the Great Hall
and Harry taught it to members of
Dumbledore's Army one of the most
notable uses of this belt was when
Malfoy used it to disarm Dumbledore
during the battle on the Astronomy tower
at number 4 on the list is the Cruciatus
curse also known as the torture curse it
is one of the three unforgivable curses
and is widely regarded as one of the
most sinister spells that can be used it
causes the victim to experience
excruciating pain pain beyond what they
could otherwise possibly conceive the
name comes from the Latin word for pain
and torture and alludes to the adjective
excruciating which is a descriptor of
its effects the Cruciatus curse was
freely used until 1717 when it was named
as one of the unforgivable curses using
the curse after 1717 would get you sent
straight to Azkaban known proponents of
this curse included Bellatrix Lestrange
Barty Crouch jr.
and Lord Voldemort it was most notably
used by Lestrange on Frank and Alice
Longbottom
driving them into complete insanity at
number three we have the Imperius curse
the Imperius curse is another of the
three unforgivable curses and is like
the Cruciatus curse widely regarded as
one of the most sinister spells that can
be used the Imperius curse when used on
a victim places them entirely under the
Castros control it is worth noting that
when the Imperius curse is performed
poorly it can result in long lasting
damage to their mind
only those with exceptional willpower
can resist it though it can be done
resisting an imperious curse can be
compared to the act of uh clemency which
closes one's mind against legitimacy
which is used to access one's mind or
thoughts
Imperius comes from the latin word
imperial which refers to things that are
powerful or commanding it was most
notably used by Harry on the goblin bank
teller bog rod in an attempt to enter
the Lestrange vault at Gringotts coming
in at number two on the list is
potentially the most powerful offensive
spell in the entire Wizarding World this
is a favorite of Lord Voldemort and is
one of the three unforgivable curses
perhaps the worst I am of course talking
about Avada Kedavra
which is used to instantly kill a victim
the only known counter spell is
sacrificial protection which was most
notably used by Lily Potter and uses the
power of love the name Avada Kedavra
comes from the word abracadabra which
means let the thing be destroyed Avada
Kedavra is used quite a bit and is most
notably used by Voldemort on his own
parents as well as Harry's by Snape on
Dumbledore and by Bellatrix Lestrange on
Sirius Black I think that it's safe to
say that there is no spell more sinister
than Avada Kedavra
coming in at number one on the list is
expect opet ronan expect to patronum
otherwise known as a Patronus charm is
used to create a protective shield
around a wizard or witch it evokes a
positive energy force known as a
Patronus which is considered to be the
spirit guardian of the caster this is
the only known defense against both
Dementors and left the folds being able
to cast a Patronus is a very difficult
feat and not many wizards are able to
achieve casting it in their lifetime it
should be safe to say that creating a
Patronus is a sign of a powerful wizard
this particular spell ranks at the top
of the list because of its defensive
capabilities you could have all of the
offense in the world but if you're
unable to defend yourself you'll be
doomed in battle it is most notably used
by Snape whose Patronus is a doe when he
wanted to help guide Harry through the
woods to the location of Godric
Gryffindor saw
well my fellow witches and wizards that
sums up today's video top seven spells
at least in our opinions and we're
pretty big Harry Potter fans so we felt
this was a good balance of the different
spells out there some deadly some
offensive and some defensive to create a
perfect balance I hope you all have a
wonderful day or night wherever you are
in the Wizarding World remember to hit
like on this video if you enjoyed it and
to see more content and until the next
episode of Harry Potter theory remember
one can never have enough socks
[Music]